Who, or what is an impostor?
Simple definition: a person who deceives others by pretending to be someone else
Full definition:
one that assumes false identity or title for
the purpose of deception
Wow, the full definition is a whopping 7 characters
more. I don't even know what to do with this
amount of time I saved reading the simple
definition first.
Let's look in the mind of someone who suffers
from impostor syndrome and see the fickle
understanding they have of their own achievements.
98 points out of 100, this surely means that they
mixed up my submission with someone else's,
who was way smarter than I am.
I went in for the next round of interviews,
messed up big time, and I got hired with an
incredible salary. This can, of course, only
be a misunderstanding.
I got elected for this prestigious award.
I don't know how this could possibly have
happened. Maybe someone who really likes me
tried to pressure the prize committee to vote
for me. I cannot possibly imagine any other
way of this happening.
I've been 5 years at the company now and still, no one found out that I am a fraud. That's a disaster
Nothing can be convince me that I am not an
impostor who fooled everyone else for being
a bright person.
However funny as it may sound, this is a very
real problem.
Researchers, academics and high achieving
women are especially vulnerable to this condition.
But it is indeed not limited to these professions.
For instance, Hayden Christensen, the actor
playing Anakin Skywalker in the beloved Star
Wars series appears to suffer from very similar
symptoms.
He said:
"I felt like I had this great thing in Star
Wars that provided all these opportunities
and gave me a career, but it all kind of felt
a little too handed to me," he explained.
"I didn't want to go through life feeling
like I was just riding a wave."
So, as a response, he hasn't really done any
acting for 4 years.
He said:
‘If this time away is gonna be damaging
to my career, then so be it. If I can come
back afterward and claw my way back in, then
maybe I’ll feel like I earned it.'”
The treatment of impostor syndrome includes
group sittings where the patients discuss
their lives and come to a sudden realization
that they are not alone and this this not
an individual case but a common pattern
among high achieving people. As they are also
very keen on dismissing praise and kind words,
they are instructed to be more vigilant about
doing that, and try to take in all the nourishment
they get from their colleagues. These are
the more common ways to treat this serious
condition that poisons so many people's minds.